MALE SPEAKER: Questions
from the audience?
And like I said keep
it concise and let's
get-- so first question.
Who's got a question?
So the question is- where's
the hardware in all of this?
Are we lagging behind
on the hardware side?
What do you see coming
around the corner?
TONY: Don is in the restroom.
He should answer this.
I think he effectively
answered it.
Here you go.
Did you hear the question?
DON: I did not
hear the question.
TONY: It's about hardware.
One more time--
DON: One more time,
what is the question?
TONY: Where is the 60
frames a second hardware?
When is that coming,
is the question.
DON: The 60 frames
a second hardware.
TONY: The true 60 frames per
second enabling hardware,
when is that coming?
DON: For PS4 or just in general?
OK.
Well I mean you
can hit that now.
It just really depends
on your application.
So I mean it's there.
You can boot up the FPS
tracker and actually see
what you're doing.
And you can
certainly hit 60 FPS,
but yeah, I'm not really sure
what we're getting at here.
TONY: All right I'm
going to add to that.
I think Don already answered it.
Here's the thing-
any application
you write can run at
one frame per second,
on really good hardware.
It's all about how you
write the software.
Don spoke about earlier.
So, yeah, there's going
to be some sensitivity.
Some devices are going to
run faster than others.
But in general, I think you
need to performance profile
for any device
you're building for,
and you get 60 FPS on anything,
if you build your application
correctly.
Do you add to that?
He doesn't want to touch that.
Next?
MALE SPEAKER: 10
foot pole, anyone?
So yes?
DON: So the question
was, can you
browse WebGL content on the PS4?
The answer is no, not
at this current time.
Don't look at me like that.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: Follow up, why?
DON: I mean obviously, we
want to enable more and more
for our browser.
At this current
time, we don't enable
WebGL for just general
things on the web.
That could potentially change
at some point in the future,
but I can't really say
when or where or why that
would be the case.
So I figured I
get this question,
but I very much apologize
for my evasive answer there.
TONY: The question has
there been much acceptance
of the glTF format in the
general web community so far?
Right?
Answer, no.
But there's a good
reason for that,
which is we're really not
promoting it too much yet.
I talk about in my talks.
Fabrice mentioned it in passing.
It's a new format.
In fact, we have not even
published a specification yet.
But we're doing all the
work out in the open.
The spec itself is written in
a JSON schema that you can go
look at.
There's like zero pros.
If you want a tutorial
on it, forget it.
You got to come talk to me
and Fabrice or whatever.
But it's all being
done out in the open.
We're building prototypes
out in the open.
Fabrice has got one on
the montage JS framework.
I've built one on
three.js that loads glTF.
I showed it to you tonight.
So all that's being
done out in the open,
but the Khronos Group-- and
this is a Khronos project--
these are the people
who made the COLLADA
format and the WebGL
standard, in fact--
are doing it as an R&D
project that at some point
we want to promote as
maybe a new standard.
Essentially as
the kind of format
that you would do with
COLLADA back in the day-
get all your data out of
your modeling packaging
and into an application,
but this one for the web.
We're going to do that
someday, maybe this year,
but we did not want to rush it.
We actually spoke about trying
to standardize this this year.
Game developers conference
coming up in March--
we want to get the
standard all ready
and get people
using and all that.
And then Remi, who's not here
tonight-- Remi Arnaud who
created COLLADA--
said, why do we get it
right first a little bit
more, get developers using it,
and then we'll
start promoting it?
And then we'll start
trying to standardize it?
So long story short, it's
still a little bit early.
I am having individual
conversations
with lots of people
who want to try
to build it into
an application now.
But we're talking about kind of
a 0.8 version of the formats.
Really not cooked yet.
So that was question one.
MALE SPEAKER: Right on.
We only have one
question per person--
TONY: Oh there we go.
Sorry, Josh.
MALE SPEAKER: Come
back to that one.
We have other
people-- go for it.
DON: I mean honestly I--
MALE SPEAKER:
Repeat the question.
DON: OK so he was asking if
I actually had more time,
what exactly would I
do further on the PS4?
I mean I really felt as though
I hit all the things I wanted
to hit, in terms of the
whole optimization thing.
Obviously, there's a lot of
other people's code involved,
because this was
basically a port.
I mean if I were doing the
whole thing-- me, myself,
and I-- I'd probably avoid
JavaScript and probably
go with something like Dart.
Especially now, because
at this point in time,
it's better to think of
JavaScript as nothing more
than assembly language, and
use the tools, and languages
you actually feel productive in.
So in that sense, I feel
a whole hell of a lot
more productive in Dart.
And I did kind of
want to go that route,
but didn't want to add
any additional overhead,
because I was interfacing with
a bunch of JavaScript code.
TONY: So the demo I showed
earlier, the Unreal Engine
demo, was done with this
technology called Emscripten.
Emscripten takes code that has
been compiled by a C compiler
or C++ compiler into what
they call intermediate code.
It's basically byte
codes that ultimately
get turned into machine language
by the time the executable has
been linked.
So if you're building something
for Windows or the Mac,
you'll use a C compiler
and ultimately, you'll
get machine code.
But it goes through this thing
called LLVM, intermediate code.
Emscripten takes that LLVM and
somehow, miraculously, turns it
into JavaScript that can be
executed in your web browser.
The tool was built at
Mozilla, the Firefox folks.
And they actually have done
a bunch of different ports
and projects with it.
The most notable one being
this Unreal Engine level
I showed you.
They did this in a week.
Now I'm sure this was
a week of like five
people on each team for
Mozilla and Unreal, Epic Games.
I don't have the
details on that,
but I'm guessing, because
it's pretty involved.
I am now currently working on
an Emscripten project myself,
so I could tell you firsthand,
I went back and did something
I haven't done and didn't
think I would do for years,
which was get a Windows machine.
[LAUGHTER]
I'm even running Windows 8.
I won't say anymore.
I got a C++ compiler.
That was OK.
I mean it's been a few
years, but I did it.
I compiled stuff, and then I
ran this Emscripten tool on it.
And it actually is working.
And I've spent about two
weeks on this project I'm on.
I can't say what it is.
And it's not well documented.
My biggest complaint,
if anything,
is the tools seem
to work, but you've
got to spend a
lot of time trying
to intuit what's going on.
But what I showed
you-- that 60 frames
a second, well 30
on my machine--
but I've seen running at 60
on some higher end hardware,
does a great job.
We're getting this really
great frame rate from something
that, if you think
about it-- I don't
know if you know
Unreal-- the app itself,
the games are built in
a scripting language.
So we not only have C++ code
compiled into JavaScript,
the JavaScript itself is
running a language interpreter
for Unreal script, which
the game was written in.
So we have a
cross-compiled application
that's got an embedded
scripting language
interpreter running in it.
And if any of you guys
know what interpreters are,
you know that's a big deal.
And I mean you saw yourself.
That was kind of amazing.
Long story short is
Emscripten is great,
but you've got to suffer through
a lot of lack of documentation.
And Google's your
friend on that one.
There's a lot of
people out there
who've suffered through
the same problems as you
and that's what I've
been doing this week.
There you go.
MALE SPEAKER: OK so me
coming from the real time
communications aspect, I think--
[AUDIENCE]
MALE SPEAKER: No.
Yes, so the first
question was, what
is the question that I should
be asking a year from now?
What are the challenges
going forward, right?
So one of the biggest
hypes these days
is connected devices, right?
This is where the real
time communication
plays an absolutely critical
role- how it's all done,
how it's all managed.
We have these gazillions
of devices out there.
Another absolutely critical
question in this space,
is security.
Once you open up your home,
you open up your health,
you open up basically your
personal stuff, that's
going to be absolutely crucial.
And then the question
is, what happens
when things just don't work-
like you are on a subway,
or you are you're
on an airplane?
These are kind of the tough
questions in our space.
TONY: I think in
a year from now,
I'm going to be asking this-
why are people still writing
JavaScript to do basic stuff?
Why am I not authoring the tags?
I mean JavaScript's fine-- pick
your language, Dart, whatever.
Why am I not just creating
content fluidly just in a web
browser, 3D multimedia
content, the way
I used to with some HTML tags?
I mean, JavaScript's great.
Canvas is great God
bless all these API's.
We wouldn't be where
we are without them,
but why am I solving the same
problems I was last year?
So in a year from now, if there
aren't tags for doing your 3D,
and your other rich
media, I'm going
to start asking those questions.
DON: Actually with yours, I mean
some of the stuff with Polymer
looks very promising.
I believe there are
actually some demos where
you can do that sort of
thing already, and just sort
of do markup in 3D.
So it could very
well be a thing.
AUDIENCE: But Don--
DON: Yeah?
AUDIENCE: What will
you do next year?
[LAUGHTER]
DON: That is a
very good question.
TONY: Don's boss is in the room.
DON: Yeah exactly.
Well I mean, more or less with
the web, where it's going,
I am very interested
in how we can
build better
applications on the web.
WebGL is certainly
awesome and I enjoy,
yet-- you're like, get
to the point already.
Thank you, Teo.
I'm more or less interested
in seeing where the web goes,
how we're going to
push it, and sort
of what the new
technologies are.
AUDIENCE: Where are
we going to push it?
DON: Well I mean I think
web components are really
where the web it's going to go,
because developing with the DOM
is pretty shitty.
And we need to, more or less,
keep pushing more of our apps
to the web.
I mean it's a great idea.
You get the collaboration.
You get the mash ups.
You get all these things.
And that's really where
applications should be going.
I am very interested in
kind of pushing where
3D is sort of fits
into that space,
so that's what
I'm interested in.
Is that sufficient?
[LAUGHTER]
MALE SPEAKER: Right.
What I think is
interesting here is
that what we do
now when we start
defining these ways
to work with the web
and WebGL is that we have a
great responsibility in doing
so, because we will define
how people will work it.
And that means
that we will define
if this will be a good thing,
if it will be the next big thing
or not.
But it's also great
responsibility--
it is the greatest
but it's also a great
opportunity to do that.
So in a year, I think we need to
ask ourselves, did we succeed?
And when it comes to the old
organic ecosystem view on it
as you said, we need different
ways to push our apps through.
We need ways to connect the
publishers with the creators.
And even if you don't
know what you're doing,
you should be
able-- as you said--
even people that have no idea
what the web is, or haven't
seen a browser before,
should be able to get
in touch with publishers
if they have great content.
So I think that's
what's going to be
a great big challenge
in a year from now.
MALE SPEAKER: I'm
probably just going
to be wondering how I can
make digital caffeine,
so I don't have to go
out and buy it anymore.
That's it.
MALE SPEAKER: I think
I'd be wondering, what's
my spot on the waiting list
for the next [INAUDIBLE]
So I think we have time
for one more question,
then we go off to the raffle.
And for those of
you in the overflow
rooms-- look at the
camera, over there-- you
can come in here for the
raffle to make it easier,
so we don't have to
call out and all that.
So one more question.
Who's got the final question?
Maybe your second question?
[AUDIENCE QUESTION]
TONY: No.
[LAUGHTER]
MALE SPEAKER: There was
someone else getting up there.
Yep.
OK, go ahead.
[AUDIENCE QUESTION]
DON: You know, none of us are
actually on the Chrome GPU
team, so there are some
people hanging around
from the Chrome GPU team.
One might be hiding
themselves in the back.
So, yeah, Ken.
[APPLAUSE]
TONY: Ladies and gentlemen,
for those who don't know,
this is Kenneth Russell.
He's the WebGL
Working Group Chair.
And he works at Google.
And he makes WebGL that works
in Chrome, which is awesome.
So Ken, you going to give
us a sneak peek at WebGL 2?
KEN: OK so first of all, Tony
gives me far too much credit.
Where's Brandon and Vangelis?
So those guys back there,
please stand up and wave.
So this is Brandon
Jones, who did
many of the really super
cool WebGL demos, including
iOS rage in WebGL, who's
now a member of our team.
Thank you for joining.
And Vangelis Kokkevis,
our boss, please tell him
how great we are.
Thank you very much.
AUDIENCE: You're awesome.
KEN: OK so Tony gives
me far too much credit.
You know there's this joke about
the parrot, who's the chairman.
We don't know what he does,
just they call him Chairman.
It's funnier if
you tell the joke.
So WebGL 2, so Khronos
released a new version
of OpenGL ES that runs
in your mobile phones.
And most phones that
are coming out now
actually have this standard.
It's of vast improvement over
the previous version that's
on previous generation
mobile devices
and what WebGL's
currently based on.
At Google, and at
Mozilla, and at Apple,
we've been working on getting
the baseline current WebGL
really robust.
We had some bugs in Chrome.
In Chrome 29, you may remember,
WebGL was flaky on Windows.
That's a real problem, because
you developers cannot deploy
your content in confidence
knowing that maybe it'll break
down some browsers.
Then you fall back to something
else, Canvas, something 2D.
You have to redesign
your whole app,
because you can't rely
on the new technology.
So at Google anyway,
we've been working
on retrenching and
really making sure
that that baseline is robust.
And we're almost done
with that big push.
So the next big push to be
finish the WebGL 2 spec, really
get to work on the
implementation.
And I said this in a meetup a
year ago, or six months ago,
saying, wait six months.
And now I'm saying, well
just wait another six months.
But we're getting there.
And I think that the
testing infrastructure
will be much better so that you
can be guaranteed that you're
going to be able to deploy
this stuff immediately as soon
as it's turned on.
AUDIENCE: What will it
do when it grows up?
MALE SPEAKER: Take
over the world.
KEN: Yeah I think it'll
probably reach mid-adulthood,
and then need some
coffee with milk in order
to stay awake or
something like that.
So it'll do some turbulence
issue simulations on the GPU.
I'm pretty sure.
AUDIENCE: Sorry, say that again?
KEN: It'll be doing its
own turbulence simulations
on the GPU for its
own milk and coffee.
Yeah that's what WebGL
3 is going to do.